hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on 400 gun and today is
part two or episode two of the hero
concept style videos that we've been
doing if you haven't seen part one
definitely go check that out it'll be in
the I on the top right but it'll also be
at the very end of this video so you can
go right to it we covered a concept for
a samurai weapon and a night hero said
have to go check that out but on today's
lists we have a viking hero a Wulin hero
and a samurai hero for your pleasure
today and I want to switch it up for
next video I want to take your
suggestions pretty much what we've been
doing is going on Reddit and looking at
other people's suggestions but I want to
get yours so right now in the comments
if you want to or when you're done
finishing this video go into the
comments and leave a comment down below
for as little or as much information as
you want on a character that you would
like within the game it could be in a
completely original idea it could be a
character that already exists or some
type of warrior that already exists you
can give as little information as you
want or as much information as you want
either way I'm gonna try to add in my
own little bits and maybe some lore
pieces to really flesh out the character
but I want to take your ideas so I'm
gonna be going through this video and
the past video is checking out comments
and seeing what people write but what
that out of the way like to be if you do
enjoy subscribers renew I cover the
informational slide a foreigner that
being the balance changes to hear
updates the Patchett's of the leaks
ivona be kept today with everything
happening in the world of foreigner and
never miss out on or not big definitely
stay subscribe the channel
and with that let's get started with
today's video and to start off today's
video we have the first one being an
in-depth lower concept of a hero called
it su madre from cake master on reddit
it's a samurai axe hero and I know what
you're thinking I get it give me one
second to explain that part but it
states that it su madre is a legendary
bird within Japanese folklore they
appear at times of famine or warfare
making a horrifying cry of it su madre
which in japanese means until when
questioning how long the disaster will
go unnoticed
the itsumademo for honor universe are
going to be elite warriors summoned by
the time of crisis there used to be
protectors and masters at temples and
dojo and now they're dragged into
warfare they're strong and deadly and
just like the name implies they will not
stop until the suffering of the Empire
was
and peace is once again possible now
this is a nice little interesting
concept and take on the character
because currently in year 4 season 1 we
already have that kind of piece going on
but maybe in season 2 something will go
awry and we'll be back to conflict again
like we had last year and via you know
one faction betraying the rest of the
other factions that's maybe why these
guys got dragged into warfare in the
first place now I'm not well-versed in
samurai folklore in their history in
general but for my searches this seems
to be either an entirely original
character name or someone taking the
place of a being like your we've already
covered it yours lore in depth before in
a past video which I'll leave a link to
that in the top right that you can check
out now but for a quick TLDR Yurman
Gunder is the name of the character but
it's also the name of the world serpent
in Norse mythology
obviously you're isn't some giant
serpent just has the name the reason is
because of course you're Miz a cult
member dedicated to you know pleasing
the world serpent but it could be in
some kind of form like this where maybe
they kind of appreciate this bird maybe
took up the name of the bird because of
what they do I think that that's kind of
the way that this is going the only
issues is the rest of the characters see
this was made last year with the intent
of using the year 3 teaser image as a
reference for the weapon the giant
samurai axe and seeing as that character
already exists he Toki REE this part
wouldn't be possible but thanks to some
artwork from Cake master this actually
looks very similar to the corrupted monk
from Sakura so we could use this as a
balance point for that part and first
being the weapon I'm still unsure what
the weapon is called in second row that
the corrupted monk uses but either way
this is a weapon that no character on
the samurai faction has and can be thus
be the unique weapon of the character
obviously we're getting a little bit too
close to you know copyright territory
with this literally just being the
corrupted monk from Sakura but once
again these are all just concepts none
of this is going to be true so just some
ideas that the community has come up
with and at the end of the day it's just
for some good fun however they have much
I'll still add to this character but I
think the overall idea would be pretty
fantastic once again even though it's
pretty much a copy of the corrupted monk
I don't see an issue with that being
added to the game because the corrupted
monk is a personal favorite of mine
stuff is our boi wolf dog again who
created the hybrid hero links to all of
his stuff down below and on screen he's
a fantastic artist and he's like I
stated created a hybrid hero who could
both fit in the knight and Viking
faction called the Varangian guard a
quick lore blurb on the Varangian guard
the guard was an elite unit of the
Byzantine Empire from the 10th to the
14th century the guards started in the
second Roman Empire the member served as
personal bodyguards to the Byzantine
emperors these guys were as diverse as
it really gets there they had some
people from the roost people during the
beginning where the Byzantine service
started then came Scandinavians Swedish
people and even some Anglo Saxons the
group as well so a very diverse cast of
characters here the guard was also used
in battle during critical moments or in
times when the battle was most fierce
and this might even tie into the
previous character about the current
piece and you know in season one that we
have being torn down in season two as
that would most definitely count as a
critical moment within a war but for the
picture wolf dog always leaves us some
beautiful pointers and from top to
bottom says the face would be covered in
some sort of chainmail the medal on the
helmet is to indicate the wealth of the
soldier there's also the weapon being a
two-handed combat axe on alternatively
having a shield on the back when not
used but of course it currently will
stay there if not used but of course can
be brought out when needed it's a combo
will have a one-handed ex and then
lastly has some nice little pouches on
the side for that nice sweet gold and
loot so this is probably gonna be one of
the most unique takes of weapons I've
seen so far to date with these videos so
most of the case we get one character
with one weapon or sometimes we get a
you know a character with two weapons
this could be the first introduction of
characters with three weapons and the
customization part obviously you have
three pieces of armor and three pieces
of a weapon this character instead of
being like most of the cast and having
one weapon with either the blade the
handle or the guard being interchanged
it could just have three weapons which
that with the whole thing being changed
al wants none of the individual parts I
know that sounds crazy but I'm thinking
of this could be used in somehow and
some combos maybe the one-handed axes
for light attacks the two-handed axes
heavies only and then
when needed between the two and the
shield could be a full block potential
move but only like a quick stab or a
head but like warlord has as to not have
a thousand moves for the character I'm
not so much worried about this from a
balance standpoint because once again
this is all just fun and games I'm more
wondering if a character is even
possible of even wielding three
different weapons at once and
interchanging them on the fly so if
that's a bit too complicated even for
other people to do I would say that
getting rid of the shield and having it
as a cosmetic as shaman has some
similarities within her outfits as well
I would just rather have the 1-handed
2-handed axes for attacking and then for
the last character we have fat chalupa
and he's decided on the J no say and
their weapon is the Pyong GaN ID or
flail staff which I'm gonna be calling
it the foil staff for the rest of this
video these names are insanely hard to
pronounce
they have good range and hit hard with
their attacks their fighting style
consists of charged heavies and zones
used in mix ups and they're pretty much
gonna be your standard shock trooper and
foreign Ally and with phat Chiapas
inspiration being Korean warriors for
some story the Jeannot se have a long
and storied past with the Wulin but this
new war proves they have more in common
than knots they wear heavy armor and
wield a bizarre flail staff making them
unstoppable in battle our many dynasties
have had no small number of enemies but
as empires rise and fall so do grudges
the Jeannot say come from lands that
have both known peace and war with the
Wulin now as we find enemies in these
new lands our alliance grow stronger and
stronger these warriors bear heavy armor
making them unstoppable on the
battlefield their weapons are strange
flails metaphor mounted combat but as
their people have shown time and time
again our true warrior can make anything
possible
I like this interesting take on the
character actually from that story it
seems like the Jeannot say this group or
wherever they resided from was actually
kind of enemies or at least not on the
best of terms with the Wulin at times
and now because of a enemy you know the
enemy of my enemy is my friend kind of
situation they decided [ __ ] it I hate
this guy - and you hate this guy let's
become friends and fight these guys
together and we'll worry about our
conflict later and I think that's a
really nice introduction
to the character and how they fit in
with the Wulin this weapon is also the
first introduction of a nunchuck like
weapon that we have in the game and I'm
a super huge fan of though so I'm
totally down for the character it is
mostly used as a horseback weapon as
stated but as like it said a true
warrior can make anything possible he
also has some nice images put together
and I gotta admit these [ __ ]
are strapped bro
like look at this guy my man's is
literally a walking disco ball in a good
way of course I think the armor on this
guy would be fantastic some of the
fashion that he would have would be out
of this world and I think honestly even
his default armor would be considered s
tier as well oh yeah that was it for
today's video guys I noticed I went a
bit too long in some of the parts in the
past video so I wanted to speed that up
a little bit for some of these
characters to try fitting a third one
I'm trying not to do like five or six
characters as this series would just be
two episodes long so I'm trying to not
do as many per video but what the ones
that I do within said video I've chosen
add a lot more depth into the character
to help kind of really drive home the
inspiration and picture of these
Warriors of course obviously these are
my own original ideas I'm just giving a
bit more backstory than some of the
things have been provided to of course
give you more depth on the character
either way let me know what your
favorite in the comments down below is
as well as what I said before about your
idea for a hero so you can have your
chance in appearing in a future video
I'm definitely big fan of the eat zoom
Ave something about seeing a human sized
version of the corrupted monk is
exciting so many moves could be done
with this character and the weapon that
the monk wields would be absolutely
insane
just to be existing in the game in the
first place but anyway I like the V if
you do enjoy guys subscribe if you're
new I covered the informational site a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the here updates the patch notes and the
leaks it's gonna be kept till today with
everything happening in the world of
foreigner and never miss out on an
update that please do subscribe to the
channel I guys take care of girls today
P so I'll see you for part 3 good bye
[Music]
you
[Music]